on the surface the shape of water shares
many similarities with its namesake it's
graceful fragile and seems tangible
however upon diving through the initial
layer many will discover that death
lurks within its vast and current themes
avoiding the fact that I've just managed
to fit in four water jokes there this
movie should be applauded and taken
seriously for the severity of its
thematic choices the most noticeable
being white privilege when first
watching the shape of water I was
instantly hit with the clear metaphor of
black oppression our monster represents
the struggle that many black people into
your daily under the slave trade during
its prominence mere centuries ago locked
in Chains experimented on and viewed as
exempt from civil rights even though the
creature clearly exerts humanity one
would be a miss for not noticing the
glaring similarities to the past of
black people looking at our own history
there is no avoiding how closely the
movie mirrors the key characteristics of
this horrendous period during the slave
trade black people were viewed as
non-human animals and therefore were
excluded from the rights that we now all
take for granted this is similar to the
way that the water creature is dissected
and discussed by government officials
and those deemed is above it objectified
death is all that remains for the
creature once it is decided that no use
remains for it and there exists a lack
of empathy for all that are classed as
the other however as we take the
perspective of eliezer we follow the
open mindedness of those that helped to
end the tragic conditions that allowed
slavery and racism to thrive we learn
that the monster is beautiful majestic
and shouldn't be demonized for being
different as Eliza spends more time with
the creature it becomes more human-like
and perfectly incorporates modern life
into its own eliza is the perfect
synonym for the decline of a racist mind
state similar to the way that civil
rights activists stood in the 50s and
60s she gains her voice and begins to
speak out and rebel against her
oppressors contrasting this is Michael
Shannon's Kara
Shannon's character embodies to a tee
the sort of toxic masculinity that is
currently dominating our daily news
cycle quite intentionally to echoing the
boast over them braggart reality TV star
Strickland muses to his general that
even after a minor accident at the lab
he still has his [ __ ] finger to do the
Lord's work and like so many men who
felt insulated in their power over women
for millennia Strickland later attempts
to corner Lisa in his office at one
point
whispering between heavy breaths that I
don't mind you can't speak this
symbolizes that he prefers a lack of
rebellion or questioning of his actions
Society has placed him at the top of the
food chain and he is deaf to anything
that might affect that pedestal like
everything else about the shape of water
there is nothing Pro typical or broad
about Shannon's performance
Eliza's daily miseries are implicitly
linked with his impunity over her and
everyone else in the film set in a 1962
corner of America that looks like the
50s are still thriving Strickland is a
layered monster made of fleshy white
privilege in Thailand and everything
else that is supposedly great about this
time in his one scene with a black man
in the film he towers over the stronger
figure like a malevolent God confident
in the social structures that allow him
to talk and cow people of color in any
context conversely Eliza and her one
friend that even lonelier Giles live in
the shadows is essentially throwaways
Giles is a not so closeted gay man who
lost his job at an advertising agency
after an incident and continues to lust
after young men from afar but he is
condemned to stay in the margins in a
world possessed by Strickland and the
beast of his L that is perhaps why he to
eventually understands Eliza's empathy
and passion for the amphibian man there
is something Noble and pure about being
who judges all men and women by their
virtue and not their rank as the film
progresses so does the growth and
decline of all key characters or gay and
mute female characters step forward and
make their mark on society putting a
dancing their beliefs in contrast to
their shannon's wanes and fades this is
the perfect summation of the recent
growth of women and gay rights and the
end of the film while it's not perfect
showcases that as a people we have
changed in unexpected ways and grown as
a species spreading into new areas that
we never thought possible similar to
this film we should learn to accept
those that are different as much as we
do the familiar and this piece works
perfectly as a metaphor of our times
like the shape of war are our
acceptances are able to fit and adapt to
any container that we are placed in and
we should never stop trying to fit the
world around us so that is my thoughts
on the hidden meaning within the shape
of water what did you think of the film
did this movie stop you wing in swimming
pools because someone lives there
comment below and let me know also check
out my recent video discussing the
ending of the Cloverfield paradox and
make sure you subscribe to my channel as
I do film game and comic discussions
weekly and I'm sure there's something
here that you will love take care peace
this was my best video ever
is it is that this is this I think this
piece is my best video ever movie of a
goldfish I'm not slacking fish people
off my no don't unsubscribe